take a pagan festival chariot pulled by
bikes and a tiny Welsh town and you get
whatever this is this story takes place
in the Welsh country died in the town of
landward land wordid plummeted well we
are the smallest town in the UK and this
is Lindsay Kettering ham he runs the
local hotel in town it called the nayeth
Arms Hotel down today is a small farming
community primarily everybody knows
everybody else day-to-day life is
generally pretty quiet around here
except on event day the mountain bike
Chariot Racing Championship is an event
that was conceived to be part of a Roman
festival rock the held each January the
rules of the race are to get round in
the fastest time possible the course
starts off on a short tarmac stretch
then becomes a rough stony road with
puddles and bumps and eventually comes
back to the finish along a tarmac
stretch which has speed bumps it's not a
simple task we do encourage people to
dress up as the Romans did as you can
see people enter into the spirit of it
which is what it's all about okay but
then her style bike racing isn't
everything that this tiny town does we
do the events such as Mungo's of course
bog snorkelling and it all started back
in the 70 so noted Wells was the center
of the pony trekking industry in Britain
and in the 1970s unfortunately the
industry went in
serious decline at that point the local
business people started looking for
ideas to boost the economy and came up
with the idea of running events things
that were slightly different and unusual
it's great to see the success of the
event see people enjoying themselves and
it's great to be able to share what this
part of the countryside has to offer
the aim is to maintain the great
community that we have here even to help
it grow but not too much we don't want
to lose our smallest towns later
hey I hear you Lyndsey
[Music]